salut à tous j'ai passé vous avez
remarqué mais on nous bassine à longueur
d'année avec légèrement climatique
franchement 2 degrés ça casse pas trois
pattes à un canard négatif parce que
deux degrés sur la planète entière ça va
être une situation catastrophique je
fais pas comme il faut non non non non
c'est bien de s'inspirer de ce qui se
fait sur internet c'est pas une mauvaise
idée si si c'est clairement une mauvaise
idée et puis surtout dave l'a déjà fait
bon nicolas a fait appel à nous pour
qu'on trouve quelque chose d'original
pour sensibiliser internet c'est pas
pour faire un lipdub sait ce qu'est ce
qui nous manque c'est quelque chose de
visuellement puisse envoyer un truc
paraissent quoi badass banes finish en
plus dans un monde où l'inconscience de
l'homme a totalement déséquilibré le
climat ou les catastrophes naturelles
sont de plus en plus fréquentes
un homme seul décide de se lever contre
tous pour leur [ __ ] une bonne grosse
raclée son nom nicolas yolo peut-être
pas être pas dit les ampoules là c'est
des ampoules basse consommation world
est sûr de ça je crois pourtant pour moi
loana base comme l'eau mais sans l'omi
moi même j'ai un peu peur qu'on le
prenne pas au sérieux quand même pour
moi c'est pas le bon message si on peut
essayer d'être un peu moins pessimiste
il a raison il faut qu'on trouve quelque
chose de plus simple une idée réaliste
que n'importe qui peut comprendre des
gays quoi tu veux tirer sur mon doigt
pour voir comment ça fait ok
mais ça ne marche pas c'est bizarre il
peut plus péter parce que prout
c'est du méthane et le méthane est un
gaz à effet de serre briller donc en
fait il avait compris ok ok mais je
pense que si on veut agir plus
efficacement pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre maintenant c'est
la responsabilité des politiques et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là il faut les
secouer
il faut qu'on trouve une idée qui
mobilise un maximum de personnes et
qu'ils soient partagées dans le monde
entier jesse et qui délivre un message
clair quitte à frapper du poing sur la
table
c'est maintenant messieurs les
dirigeants qu'il faut agir demain ça
sera trop tard parce que c'est trop tard
des hommes tapis costa s'est pas il fait
froid les soins laisse-moi laisse moi
faire laisse moi faire ça lui botte de
[ __ ] des gouvernements du monde
vous voyez ça c'est ta planète alors
vous vous êtes là si vous mettez pas
d'accord et bah voilà ce qui va se
passer
hélas beaucoup trop violent faudrait
qu'on partir un peu plus oui moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'on délivre un
message de paix ouais et guay et qua non
ah bon d'autant qu'on n'a toujours pas
parlé de la pétition pour ça j'ai ma
petite idée
salut à tous et que yann et aujourd'hui
on va tester un tout nouveau personnage
dans street fighter captain coop 21 et
je suis avec son créateur nicolas hulot
fallu alors explique moi les coups
spéciaux de ce nouveau personnage de
simples avant arrière pousseurs de là il
sort une pétition est il est fière des
munitions non une pétition faute n'a pas
conscience que quand des milliers de
personnes signent une pétition c'est
hyper puissant mon truc
ok bon d'accord c'est peut-être tout
simplement je pas délivrer un message
sobre et efficace à l'américaine nan
c'est sympa on tond mais chacun son
métier mais je vois tous les caisses
d'internet qui débarque comme ceux qui
font un message émouvant de seconde
regardez bonjour bienvenue dans un
message sobre et efficace à l'américaine
pour l'occasion d'ailleurs j'ai mis une
moustache un père à la française voilà
ça fait 20 ans qu'on entend qu'il est
temps de prendre soin de notre planète
et de l'environnement alors vous vous
demandez sûrement d'accord mais quoi
faire il faut que je ferme le robinet
pendant que je me brosse les dents que
je trie bien mes déchets que je mange
bio ouais c'est vrai il faut faire tout
ça mais mais c'est pas de ça qu'on vous
parle aujourd'hui il y a un rendez vous
historique en décembre à paris
la cap 21 ce nom il est vraiment nul
mais bon plus les chefs d'état du monde
vont se réunir pour prendre des
décisions sur le climat c'est une
occasion en or pour leur rappeler qui
les a élus pourquoi ils sont à ce poste
de quoi ont-ils le plus peur de ne pas
se tarir
comment faire pression en signant la
pétition consignes
plus nous serons nombreux plus nos chefs
d'état seront obligés
alors évidemment certains diront ce
n'est pas mon combat où moi je suis
jamais répétition franchement c'est un
principe ce père dit à san antonio en
chine j'avais rêvé des sciences ou alors
je ne sais pas trop quoi penser de feu
nicolas hulot là n'est pas la question
l'enjeu est d'une importance capitale et
bien au dessus des opinions politiques
des affinités pour telle ou telle
personne ou d opinion personnelle
l'enjeu est d'enfin s'unir pour dire
d'une seule voix c'est votre dernière
chance de nous prouver qu'on nous a pas
élus pour rien ce n'est plus l'avenir
qui se décident s'ils présent nous
pouvons reprendre notre destin en main
n'ayons pas peur osons met entendre
votre voix
chaque signature compte chaque voix
compte
ok idées pour la vidéo la un mec il
vient du futur il remonte le temps avec
quoi une machine pour remonter le temps
vous suivez ok mais les grands manques
le temps il dit signez la pétition sinon
voici ce qui va arriver et la suite
c'est son image hyper culotte et rapide
soit oui c'est barrer nicolas ledoux
c'est fini je vais garder pour moi c'est
tout dit et vous l'aurez bien de tous
on